[Musique]
des histoires des aventures les élèves
de l'école d'arts d'elancourt ont fait
bourgeonner leurs esprits autour d'un
univers celui de la forêt c'est un thème
qui se prête bien à l'environnement
naturel de la ferme du mousseau on est
voilà presque presque au milieu de la
forêt en tout cas on surplombe la forêt
de la colline de la revanche
c'est aussi une manière pour les élèves
de réfléchir à l'importance de
l'environnement naturel et puis la forêt
symboliquement elle permet plein
d'aventurés en termes de poésie en
termes de danse en terme d'art visuel
arbres en devenir faune florissante
cette exposition représente plusieurs
mois de travail pour les élèves
plasticien et danseurs âgés de 8 à 18
ans c'est les élèves qui ont inventé
leur technique
c'est ça qui est génial c'est que parmi
tout ce qui est comment dire toutes les
créations des élèves qui sont sortis il
ya aussi des créations technique
donc on a des découpages décollage de la
peinture de l'installation du nahd ans
bien sûr beaucoup de créations
chorégraphiques alors comment comment
rendre compte d'une création
chorégraphique dans une exposition
on a des petites séries de photos donc
c'est quasiment de la chronophotographie
et puis on a aussi de la vidéo et on a
aussi du son le festival courants d'art
est un échanges interdisciplinaires
renforcée par des master classes cette
année ont été associés un chorégraphe
une musicienne est une artiste
plasticienne où mon domaine a été plutôt
au théâtre donc on était dans
l'informatique et la vidéo et après moi
là ces élèves ont réinterprété avec
leurs professeurs
ce qu'ils avaient reçus en traduction
sans présenter aujourd'hui les bourgeons
ne resteront qu'un temps d'une nouvelle
réflexion les fera fleurir en mai pour
parler de la frondaison